when i was in high school at the age of
17 i graduated from high school in
decatur georgia as valedictorian of my
high school
very proud of myself
i was from a low income community i'd
grown up in mississippi we'd moved from
mississippi to georgia so my parents
could pursue
their degrees as united methodist
ministers we were poor but they didn't
think we were poor enough so they were
going for permanent poverty
and so while they studied at emory i
studied at avondale and i became
valedictorian well one of the joys of
being valedictorian in the state of
georgia is that you get invited to meet
the governor of georgia
i was mildly interested in meeting him
that was kind of cool i was more
intrigued by the fact that he lived in a
mansion
because i watched a lot of general
hospital and dynasty as a child
and so i got up that morning ready to go
to visit the governor my mom and my dad
who are also invited got up and we went
outside but we didn't get in our car and
in the south a car is a
necessary thing we don't have a lot of
public transit there aren't a lot of
options but if you're lucky enough to
live in a community where you don't have
a car the only option is public transit
and that's what we had to take
and so we got on the bus and we took the
bus from decatur all the way to buckhead
where the governor's mansion sat on this
really beautiful acreage of land these
long black gates that ran the length of
the property
we get to the governor's mansion we pull
the little lever that lets them know
this is our stop we get off the bus my
mom my dad and i we walk across the
street and we walk up the driveway
because their cars coming up cars
bringing in students from all across the
state of georgia and so we're walking
along the side
and as we walk single file along the
side my mom and dad sandwiching me to
make sure i don't get hit by one of the
cars bringing in the other
valedictorians we approach the guard
gate
when we get to the guard gate the guard
comes out and he looks at me and he
looks at my parents
and he says you don't belong here this
is a private event
my dad says no this is my daughter stacy
she's one of the valedictorians
but the guard doesn't look at the
checklist that's in his hands
he doesn't ask my mom for the invitation
that's at the bottom of her very
voluminous purse
instead he looks over our shoulder at
the bus because in his mind the bus is
telling him a story about who should be
there
and the fact that we were too poor to
have our own car
that was a story he told himself and he
may have seen something in my skin color
he may have seen something in my attire
i don't know what went through his mind
but his conclusion was to look at me
again and with the look of disdain say i
told you this is a private event you
don't belong here
now my parents were studying to become
united methodist ministers but they were
not pastors yet
and so they proceeded to engage this
gentleman in a very robust discussion of
his decision-making skills
my father may have mentioned that he was
going to spend eternity in a very fiery
place if he didn't find my name on that
checklist
and indeed the man checked the checklist
eventually and he found my name and he
led us inside
but i don't remember meeting the
governor of georgia
i don't recall meeting my fellow
valedictorians from 180 school districts
the only clear memory i have of that day
was a man standing in front of the most
powerful place in georgia looking at me
and telling me i don't belong
and so i decided 20 some odd years later
to be the person who got to open the
gates
unfortunately you may have read the rest
of the story it didn't quite work out
that way
and now i'm tasked with figuring out how
do i move forward
because you see i didn't want to just
open the gates for young black women who
had been underestimated and told they
don't belong i wanted to open those
gates for latinas
and for asian americans i wanted to open
those gates for the undocumented and the
documented i wanted to open those gates
as an ally of the lgbtq community i
wanted to open those gates for the
families that have to call themselves
the victims of gun violence i wanted to
open those gates wide for everyone in
georgia because that is our state and
this is our nation and we all belong
here
[Music]
but what i recognize is that the first
try
wasn't enough
and my question became how do i move
forward how do i get beyond the
bitterness and the sadness
and the lethargy and watching an
inordinate amount of television as i eat
ice cream
what do i do next
and i'm gonna do what i've always done
i'm going to move forward because going
backwards isn't an option and standing
still is not enough
you see i began my race for governor by
and analyzing who i was and what i
wanted to be and there are three
questions i ask myself about everything
i do whether it's running for office or
starting a business when i decided to
start the new georgia project to
register people to vote or when i
started the latest action fair fight
georgia no matter what i do i ask myself
three questions
what do i want
why do i want it and how do i get it
and in this case i know what i want i
want change
that is what i want but the question is
what change do i want to see
and i know that the questions i have to
ask myself are one am i honest about the
scope of my ambition
because it's easy to figure out that
once you didn't get what you wanted
maybe you should have set your sights a
little lower but i'm here to tell you to
be aggressive about your ambition
do not allow setbacks to set you back
number two let yourself
understand your mistakes but also
understand their mistakes because as
women in particular we're taught that if
something doesn't work out it's probably
our fault
and usually there is something we could
do better but we've been told not to
investigate too much what the other side
could have done and this isn't partisan
it's people
we're too often told that our mistakes
are ours alone but victory is a shared
benefit
and so what i tell you to do is
understand your mistakes but understand
the mistakes of others
and be clear-headed about it and be
honest with yourself and honest with
those who support you
but once you know what you want
understand why you want it
and even though it feels good revenge is
not a good reason
instead
make sure you want it because there's
something not that you should do
but something you must do it has to be
something that doesn't allow you to
sleep at night unless you're dreaming
about it something that wakes you up in
the morning and gets you excited about
it or something that makes you so angry
you know you have to do something about
it
but know why you're doing it
and know why it must be done
you've listened to women from across
this world talk about why things have to
happen
but figure out what the why is for you
because jumping from the what to the do
is meaningless if you don't know why
because when it gets hard when it gets
tough when your friends walk away from
you when your supporters forget you
when you don't win your first race
if you don't know why you can't try
again
so first know what you want
second know why you want it but third
know how you're gonna get it done
i faced a few obstacles in this race
just a few
but in the pursuit i became the first
black woman to ever become the nominee
for governor in the history of the
united states of america for a major
party
but more importantly in this process
we turned out 1.2 million
african-american voters in georgia that
is more voters than voted on the
democratic side of the ticket in 2014.
our campaign tripled the number of
latinos who believe their voices
mattered in the state of georgia we
tripled the number of asian americans
who stood up and said this is our state
too
those are successes that tell me how i
can get it done but they also let me
understand that the obstacles aren't
insurmountable they're just a little
high
but they also understand that there are
three things that always hold us hostage
the first
is finances
now you may have heard i'm in a little
bit of debt
if you didn't hear about it you did not
go outside
and finances are something that holds us
back so often our dreams are bounded by
how much we have in resources
but we hear again and again the stories
of those who overcome those resources
those resource challenges
but you can't overcome something you
don't talk about
and that's why i didn't allow them to
debt shame me in my campaign
i didn't allow anyone to tell me that my
lack of opportunity was a reason to
disqualify me from running and believe
me people tried to tell me i shouldn't
run
friends told me not to run allies told
me not to run the usa today mentioned
maybe i shouldn't run
but no matter who it was i understood
that finances are often a reason we
don't let ourselves dream
i can't say that you will always
overcome those obstacles but i will tell
you you will be damned if you do not try
the second is fear and fear is real
it is paralyzing it is terrifying but it
can also be energizing
because once you know what you're afraid
of you can figure out how to get around
it
and the third is fatigue
sometimes you just get tired of trying
you get tired of reading about processes
and politics and the things that stop
you from getting where you want to be
sometimes fatigue means that we accept
position instead of power we let someone
give us a title as a consolation prize
rather than realizing we know what we
want and we're going to get it even if
we're tired that's why god created naps
but we also learn in those moments that
fatigue
is an opportunity to evaluate how much
we want it
because if you are beaten down if you
have worked as hard as you can
if you have done everything you said you
should and it still doesn't work out
fatigue
can sap you of your energy
but that's why you go back to the why of
it because i know we have to have women
who speak for the voiceless
i know we have to have people of good
conscience who stand up against
oppression
i know we have to have people who
understand that social justice belongs
to us all and that wakes me up every
morning and that makes me fight even
harder
because i am moving forward knowing what
is in my path i know the obstacles they
have for me i know what they're going to
do and i'm fairly certain they're
energizing and creating new obstacles
now
but they've got four years to figure it
out
maybe
two
but
but here
but here's my point
i know what i want and that is justice
i know why i want it because poverty is
immoral and it is a stain on our nation
and i know how i'm going to get it by
moving forward every single day thank
you so much